well every election cycle you probably
noticed more states legalized marijuana
could soon be legal nationwide likely
will be but with drug abuse of all kinds
soaring an American youth falling apart
is legalization a good idea what exactly
do we know about marijuana maybe the
stock is the author of how to smoke pot
properly and co-host of the podcast
great moments in weed history thank you
very much for coming on so I guess the
first thing I know there's a really
interesting piece of West this week by
Malcolm Gladwell in The New Yorker I'm
sure you read it and it asked and he's
kind of agnostic I think about the
question marijuana but he made the point
that we don't know that much about the
health effects of marijuana most of the
claims made by its proponents are
unproven but the c-d-c does say that
there is a relationship between
marijuana use and rising schizophrenia
rates in violence so why should we
legalize something that we know causes
schizophrenia well I mean the first
thing we need to understand is cannabis
is objectively safer than many
substances that are legal alcohol
tobacco right many pharmaceutical drugs
to get to your point about wait boy I'm
sorry how do we know that it's safer
then than alcohol and tobacco since I
don't only think we know very much about
it I mean most drugs that can we been
stuck in for hundreds of years and
alcohol for thousands we don't know that
much about them so how do why don't we
say we know that when we don't really
know that we can compare the number of
people who died from each substance
every year hundreds of thousands of
people from alcohol and tobacco and zero
people from cannabis so you know really
there's a shorthand no that's attributed
to cannabis absolutely there have been
many just not true well I'm going to if
if it is true as the CDC says that
cannabis use looks like it causes or
spread asleep so what is it what
percentage of people is answer for Nia
right no I'm saying you're looking at it
wrong if weed smoking causes
schizophrenia and there's a suggestion
that it does let's get
Bernina kills lots of people and so does
suicide and so does violence and if
marijuana use hikes rates of violence
and it seems like there's a lot of
evidence that it does then that kills
people so the question is not do they
died from lung cancer the question is do
they die from suicide or violence and
those are real questions and you don't
know the answers to them so why are you
saying it's totally safe when you you
don't know that that's true
I did not say it's totally safe that's a
ridiculous standard
strenuous exercise can lead to a heart
attack that's fatal drinking too much
water can be fatal I think you need to
understand the difference between
correlation and causation
I do understand I apparently you don't
no I do and what I understand most of
all is the is the basic precept of
science which is we don't know something
until we prove it and almost nothing
about math tell me what are you proven
so why are you acting like we know when
we don't this is what's proven to be
harmful Tucker
arresting 600,000 Americans every year
for making the choice to use a substance
that's objectively safer than alcohol
that and doing it in a way that targets
the poor and minorities
disproportionately is devastating to
those communities you're missing I'm not
arguing in favor of that when you're
making a parallel argument in it but you
don't want to you don't want anybody
always for unfair application of the law
I'm always for hassling people for
things that aren't really bothering
others but that's not really the
question so I've never been for like
rousting people from their homes for
smoking weed I'm totally against that
but that's very different from
legalizing it everywhere which increases
the rate of kids smoking weed and if it
really does cause schizophrenia I should
be really afraid of that
no well youth use is down in the states
that have legalized first of all and
second of all if it's not going to be
legalized answer me this
who's going to grow and sell this
cannabis where's it going to magically
appear from if not through a regulated
taxed industry if my aunt in Kansas
comes down with cancer where am I going
to send her to buy a safe
lab tested medical cannabis product to
save her life in your sis I think I
think rosin sells the cannabis I thought
it was the US government grew it in
Mississippi for years as you know I mean
seven people Tucker but it's not
impossible to hold on you're throwing
another red herring it's the argument
and evading the quarter if no it's look
if we use opioids legally they're
prescribed by physicians it doesn't mean
the average person can buy opium so you
could have controlled marijuana growing
for its medicinal properties which I'm
willing to believe exists I'm just
saying you're talking about legalizing
it which means many more kids will smoke
it and if it causes schizophrenia it
should scare the hell out of us but it
doesn't seem to bother you because I
don't know what you're taking money from
them or something why doesn't that
bother you
Tucker you know you're the one on here
repeating old lies old distortions
debunked claims the author of the book
that you had on last week everything he
said has been completely debunked I
don't know if you've read my article on
leaf Lee I assume that's why you had me
on know many of the people in the
studies that he cited have gone on
Twitter to say you grossly
misrepresented our findings okay
National Academy of Medicine the authors
said you misrepresent do your job let me
ask you one quality Senate one question
is it this is my real concern of
schizophrenia because I think it's such
a terrible disease and we can't cure it
in a lot of people died for a man it's
horrible as you know is it untrue do you
think that marijuana use looks like it
could increase the rate of schizophrenia
is that a fake statistic it's a sincere
question to you I'd say you know we need
to know more and we should know more but
having you and authors come on and just
confuse causation and correlation
there's no one good you would since your
question and you don't seem to be
their answer we've had societies where
the rates of cannabis use has gone way
up and the rates of schizophrenia have
not gone up at all so to me that would
put a lot of cold water on your idea
that there is an epidemic of violence I
thought you were asleep a position in
correlation but then aren't isn't that
what you're doing okay look I just look
it's an open zero engine banning
anything I just think that we don't know
that much I don't think you really know
I mean yeah I was debating you we're out
of time David thank you
I appreciate her coming on